and while sharks have always been
present along this massive shoreline
starting in 2010 they become a problem
[Music]
more than 60 attacks in just 10 years
triple the number of incidents from the
preceding decade it's an unprecedented
uptick
shark attacks in Western Australia
previously were rare now they're almost
regular events not only that the spike
includes a horrifying 11 fatalities
earning this tourist haven a terrifying
designation as Australia's deadliest
coast the amount of vicious attacks
there's no question it becomes talk of
the town
paperless gates go back in the water
with residents demanding action
authorities put prevention measures in
place including aerial surveillance and
beach enclosures but the attacks just
keep coming so investigators take up the
case in a bid to stop the bloodshed and
keep it from recurring elsewhere the
more we can research into what's
happening than the more human fatalities
and human chocolate we're going to be
able to prevent so what's causing the
Sharks of Western Australia to suddenly
go on a rampage
shark expert Johan Gustafson believes
that a crucial first step in solving
this mystery is to identify the culprit
so he turns to a piece of evidence from
the attack on Elise so here we have a
fragment of taste that was lodged within
the victim Gustafson thinks this tooth
must belong to one of three species
which are responsible for the majority
of the attacks worldwide the first is
the tiger shark so here we have a tiger
shark
jewel and we see on one side of the jaw
the blades are pointing to the lips or
on the opposite side of the jaw they're
pointing in the opposite direction this
allows Tigers to rip their prey from
both sides of their teeth
as they shake their heads back and forth
a second likely culprit is the bull
shark so with our bull shark that we
have here completely different shape up
to quite pointed serration is quite
sharp the bull sharks powerful pointed
teeth enable it to slice through its
victim in one quick lethal motion but
Gustavson believes the shape of the
tooth from Elise's wound indicates a
different predator with this tooth
fragments it's perfectly triangular and
it's quite serrated on both sides was
that data I can conclude this came from
the watch our great whites are the
largest predatory fish on the planet
they use their powerful tails to propel
them through the water and upwards of 25
miles per hour
often striking their prey from below but
this identification isn't limited to
Elise's attacker of the more than 60
attacks where the species is known the
majority of culprits are white sharks so
what's causing great whites here to act
so strangely and could it be indicative
of a behavioral shift happening across
the globe
perhaps the answer relates to a booming
industry that's centered around this
iconic species one that occurs in
several locations but all began down
under cage diving short expert dr. Dan
Hueber explains the way cage diving
operations work is that boats use Chum
to try and attract sharks to the area
people then get into cages which are
submerged in the water to get much much
closer to very dangerous sharks than
they would otherwise be able to cage
diving has been a fixture of Australian
tourism for decades but around 2010
something changed in 2010 when the spike
in shark attacks began the number of
days that chumming occurred on the water
had doubled compared to the previous
year
[Music]